Netflix is always adding top-notch movies
to its library, but it's also constantly taking
options away.
Here are the movies you have to watch before
they leave Netflix in November 2019.
Until November 1, you can dine in hell alongside
Gerard Butler's King Leonidas by watching
the 2006 action film 300.
Directed by Zack Snyder, 300 is based on Frank
Miller's comic book series of the same name,
which offers a fictionalized retelling of
the real-life Battle of Thermopylae that occurred
in 480 BC during the Greco-Persian Wars.
Butler top-lines the film as Leonidas, leader
of the Grecian city-state Sparta, who takes
300 Spartans into battle against the king
of Persia, Xerxes, and his 300,000 soldiers.
This is a flick filled with violence, action,
and bloodshed, and is sure to please anyone
keen on watching Gerard Butler swing around
a sword and kick his enemy into a pit.
"This is Sparta"
The original 1980 sports comedy film, Caddyshack
stars Chevy Chase as Ty Webb, a golfer at
Bushwood Country Club.
The elite establishment, which Ty's father
co-founded, gets a rude awakening when the
loud-mouthed, new-money golfer Al, played
by Rodney Dangerfield, takes the green.
Bushwood is also dealing with a seemingly
never-ending war between an evil gopher bent
on destroying the golf course and Bushwood's
groundskeeper Carl Spackler, who's intent
on exterminating the rodent.
Like its predecessor, Caddyshack II is also
available to stream on Netflix until November
1.
Clint Eastwood's 2008 drama Gran Torino is
a movie you certainly won't want to miss before
it leaves Netflix.
While you might know Eastwood from his time
in Westerns, Gran Torino sees the actor tackling
modern drama.
The venerated actor directs, produces, and
stars in Gran Torino, a film about a widowed
Korean War vet who forms a unique relationship
with his neighbor, Thao.
Critics have held Gran Torino in high esteem,
so if you've yet to see it for yourself, you
have until November 1 to learn why.
Until November 1, subscribers can stream Groundhog
Day, which follows Phil Connors as he relives
February 2, 1992 over and over again.
As he does, he slowly learns to respect others,
open up his heart, and even save another person
from death.
Easily one of Bill Murray's best films, you
might not get another chance to see the film
on Netflix again soon.
It's sweet, it's inventive, it spawned a whole
new meaning for the term "groundhog day,"
and it's on Netflix for only a few more days.
"I'm sorry?
What was that again?"
"I'm a god?"
"You're god?"
"I'm a god, not the god.
I don’t think."
The Scream franchise and the Scary Movie series
go together like peanut butter and jelly:
it's hard to have one without the other.
Netflix subscribers can sit down for a double
feature like no other by watching Wes Craven's
iconic slasher flick Scream, which centers
around high school student Sidney Prescott
and the masked murderer who's stalking her
and her friends.
Then you can immediately follow it up with
Scary Movie 2, a spoof on supernatural horror
movies that covers everything from The Exorcist
to The Amityville Horror.
Both flicks will stick around Netflix until
November 1.
After you've thoroughly satisfied yourself
with Halloween candy, retire to your couch
for a six-hour binging marathon.
Until November 1, Netflix subscribers can
stream The Lord of the Rings: The Two Towers
and The Lord of the Rings: The Return of the
King, the final two installments of the Lord
of the Rings trilogy.
Follow the trials and tribulations of the
fellowship as they reunite with Gandalf, orchestrate
an attack on Isengard, head to Mount Doom
in Mordor, destroy the One Ring, and fight
against the vicious Sauron.
It's high fantasy at its finest, and you've
got a few days left to enjoy it on Netflix.
Featuring one of the biggest twists in movie
history, The Sixth Sense centers around a
young boy named Cole Sear, who can see dead
people.
Cole's troubled by his paranormal abilities,
which leads child psychologist Dr. Malcolm
Crowe to find the truth behind the boy's visions.
In the end, they both get more than they bargained
for, and viewers get one unforgettable plot
twist.
The Sixth Sense is available to stream on
Netflix until November 1.
Have an extra three hours to spare and want
to spend it doing something meaningful?
Stream Richard Linklater's sprawling, deeply
intimate, Academy Award-nominated opus Boyhood.
The film follows a boy named Mason Evans Jr.
as he comes of age in Texas alongside his
younger sister Samantha.
Together with his divorced parents Olivia
and Mason Sr., Mason discovers facts of life,
and finds out what it means to be human.
Linklater took an inventive approach with
Boyhood, shooting the film over the course
of 12 years from 2001 to 2013 with the exact
same cast.
The end result is a touching depiction of
personal evolution as viewers watch Mason
literally grow up from year to year.
Boyhood leaves Netflix a little later in the
month, on November 25.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.